[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
hallo und guten abend an einem tag an
dem wir dringend auf das ganz große bild
schauen sollten das bild unserer welt in
der so viel in bewegung geraten ist das
liegt nicht nur an der pandemie und dem
krieg wobei das wort nur in diesem
zusammenhang irgendwie unpassend klein
klingt aber es geht eben auch noch um
die sorge vor einer seit jahrzehnten
nicht mehr da gewesenen hungersnot vor
verteilungskämpfen und energie notstand
es geht um zerrüttetes vertrauen und
zerrüttete lieferketten um alte
abhängigkeiten die entblößt wurden und
neue die gerade entstehen und zu alledem
kommt die herausforderung unser klima zu
retten genau genommen kommt sie nicht
dazu sie ist längst da sie bleibt und
auch wenn sie gerade häufig nachrangig
behandelt wird ohne einen planeten auf
dem wir leben können ist alles andere
egal
jetzt erstmal durchatmen
wir fürchten die risiken und ahnen dass
es auch chancen gibt ab heute trifft
sich die selbsterklärte elite dieser
erde zum weltwirtschaftsforum die
mächtigen die reichen die weichensteller
und auch die die viel entscheiden es
wartet viel arbeit aus davos anne
gellinek
diesmal ist alles anders in davos statt
bei klirrender kälte bei schnee und in
pelzmänteln trifft sich die elite aus
wirtschaft politik und gesellschaft
jetzt im grünen frühsommer nach einer
zweieinhalbjährigen pandemie und
denkpause ein weltwirtschaftsforum im
mai stellt die sicherheit vor völlig
neue probleme mehr zufahrtswege sind
geöffnet stadt verschneit der boden am
see ist nicht gefroren und deshalb zu
weich für einen hubschrauberlandeplatz
die helikopter milliardenschwerer
firmenchefs müssen draußen bleiben
also die anreise unserer teilnehmenden
das ist sache der teilnehmenden wir
hoffen natürlich dass viele die
öffentlichen verkehrsmittel benutzen wie
vor allem auch den zug
wir bieten auch shuttles an vom
flughafen nach davos
komplizierter als die anreise ist die
völlig veränderte weltlage russlands
krieg in der ukraine hat die
veranstalter gezwungen die komplette
russische delegation auszuladen das
waschhaus in dem russlands regierung in
den letzten jahren hof hielt ist jetzt
zum haus russischer kriegsverbrechen
umfunktioniert der zweitreichste mann
der ukraine
ein kiewer oligarch bietet nun die teure
immobilie an der davoser promenade und
finanziert die ausstellung die dem
schrecken des krieges ein gesicht geben
soll
displays dies ist der ort an dem alle
einflussreichen leute zusammenkommen es
ist also unwahrscheinlich wichtig dass
sich hier an dem ort wo sie darüber
nachdenken wie die zukunft der welt
aussehen soll erfahren was in der
ukraine passiert denn ein teil dieser
zukunft wird gerade in der ukraine
entschieden in uk weniger glitzer mehr
nachdenklichkeit keine russen nur wenige
chinesen wegen corona aber auch weil
sich china weiter vom westen abkoppelt
ein verkleinertes forum mit schwindenden
gewissheiten funktioniert die
globalisierung überhaupt noch die welt
spaltet sich in wirtschaftsblöcke die
einander feindlich gegenüberstehen
lieferketten reißen ab davos will
überall das nachdenken ohne dabei in
panik zu geraten
die geopolitischen spannungen sind
natürlich größer als das in den letzten
jahren waren aber als unternehmen muss
man ja gucken dass man sich damit
auseinandersetzt und trotzdem noch
geschäfte macht geld verdienen und
gleichzeitig werte verteidigen märkte
offenhalten und das klima schützen eine
verunsicherte wirtschafts elite die sich
für vier tage in die schweizer berge
zurückgezogen hat muss einiges für sich
klären
der mann der dieses treffen der welt in
den schweizer bergen erfunden hat und
leitet ist klaus schwab er ist auch der
mann mit dem adressbuch um das ihn viele
beneiden weil darin die direkten
handynummern der wichtigsten entscheider
aus politik und wirtschaft weltweit
stehen dürften
herr schwab guten abend nach davos
so viel zu besprechen und vor allem so
gewaltige dinge zu besprechen fangen wir
vielleicht mal so an wenn sie sich die
weltlage ansehen schwab und dann das was
in davos in der vergangenheit immer
besprochen und beworben wurde wie viel
müssen sie jetzt komplett neu und anders
denken
ich glaube du wirst du zum ersten mal
mit einer situation konfrontiert
wo wir verschiedene krisen
lebensbedrohende krisen gemeinsam und
gleichzeitig zu bewältigen haben dazu
gehört natürlich der krieg in der
ukraine
dazu gehört die weltwirtschaft mit einer
drohenden hungersnot auch der zug wird
der übergang von einer kuh wie tante
mimi in ein normales leben und
schließlich nicht zu vergessen die
dringende zeit die wir zur verfügung
haben um die klimafrage zu lösen sehr
sehr viele fragen großer
herausforderungen jetzt haben wir in der
vergangenheit die globalisierte welt
immer gefeiert gesehen auch gerade bei
ihnen in davos wir haben aber jetzt
gesehen wohin abhängigkeiten führen in
einer globalisierten welt abhängigkeiten
bei der energie abhängigkeiten bei
absatzmärkten stichwort russland
stichwort china kann denn unser
wirtschaftssystem all diese
herausforderungen wirklich meistern oder
muss ich dann nicht grundsätzlich etwas
ändern geht dieses immer mehr immer mehr
umsatz immer mehr gewinn wirklich so
weiter
ich bin ja ein verfechter des
sogenannten stakeholder kapitalismus das
heißt dass sein unternehmen nicht nur
den aktionären dienen muss sondern der
umwelt sorge tragen muss und auch die
leute immer im blick wenn klagen muss
diese zielsetzung wird weiter bestehen
ich sehe auch in einer welt die
fragmentierte wird umso mehr die
bedeutung einer plattform wie wir sie
haben zwischen politik und wirtschaft
die informell ist die aber gleichzeitig
das vertrauen aller beteiligten und hat
und die auch die akuten probleme direkt
anspricht aber wenn man noch mal bei dem
thema bleiben dass diese welt über ihre
ressourcen lebt und eigentlich massive
probleme hat am ende genau deshalb ist
das ein bisschen viel verlangt
ausgerechnet von den managern in davos
zu verlangen dass sie darum denken
nein ich glaube wir haben es mit einer
systemkrise zu tun und sowohl die
unternehmen als auch die politik und die
zivilgesellschaft hat dazu beizutragen
es gibt keine
patentlösung für all diese probleme ich
glaube wir müssen dem kleinen jeder für
sich müssen wir beraten arbeiten das
system zu reparieren und hier ist jeder
herausgefordert und was wir in da wo es
tun ist die notwendigen plattformen
willen zur zusammenarbeit aber auch dem
einzelnen zu vermitteln was getan werden
muss in dieser situation wo wir mit so
vielen problemen gleichzeitig
konfrontiert sind es war termins
mehrfach schon zusammenarbeit gesagt
aber gerade in der pandemie haben wir
doch festgestellt dass es wenig globale
solidarität gibt und in dieser großen
krise dann doch eher jeder an sich
selbst gedacht hat
das stimmt die pandemie hat uns alle
egoistische gemacht sie hat staaten
nationalistische gemacht aber trotzdem
haben wir gemeinsame interessen denken
sie vor allem an die umwelt denken sie
an die bessere vorbereitung für die
nächste pandemie hier brauchen wir
globale zusammenarbeit hier brauchen wir
eine plattform und das ist was da wo es
bezweckt und
was wir versuchen zu leisten sie haben
die umwelt angesprochen wir sehen jetzt
ganz aktuell plötzlich kriegsfolgen und
klimaschutz als als eine art gegensatz
also nach dem motto erst mal müssen dass
eine bewältigen und dann kann das andere
kommen wir erleben einen innenminister
der gas terminals baut wir haben gestern
hier in der sendung über australien
berichtet dass gerade seine kohle
verkauf zu top preisen und immer mehr
kohle abbauen will wie bekommt man denn
das jetzt wieder zusammen und zwar
schnell
das stimmt aber wir dürfen nicht eine
krise nach der anderen bewältigen
sondern wir müssen simultan vorgehen ich
weiß das ist sehr schwierig ich weiß
dass überfordert manche leute aber wenn
wir das nicht tun wenn wir erwarten zum
beispiel bei der lösung der ganzen
umweltprobleme dann zahlen wir später
einen viel höheren preis um eine lösung
zu erzielen
sehen sie denn jemanden sehen sie auch
jemanden in davos von all den mächtigen
und einflussreichen die sie dabei
herbergen der dafür eine wirklich
tragfähige lösung hätte
ich glaube die lösung kommt zusammen
durch den dialog wir haben zum beispiel
alle massgebenden persönlichkeiten die
in der bekämpfung der klimakrise
engagiert sind haben wir hier in davos
zusammen china usa trotz der
verschiedenen gegensätze und wir hoffen
natürlich dass diese gespräche doch
gewisse fortschritte gemacht werden es
war pier wirtschaftsforums präsident hat
gerade gesagt es geht uns schlechter als
letztes jahr aber besser als im nächsten
sind sie da optimistischer
ich bin
vorsichtiger ich würde sagen es könnte
uns im wechsel via schlechter gehen wenn
wir unsere verantwortung nicht
wahrnehmen und die verantwortung liegt
dem nicht nur bei politiker dabei
unternehmen oder weiter zu viel
gesellschaft sondern es liegt an uns
allen gemeinsam die notwendigen
anstrengungen zu unternehmen das
bedeutet zum beispiel im klimabereich
nicht nur zu fordern das unternehmen zum
beispiel klimaneutral werden es bringt
auch einen wandel in unserem lebensstil
das bedingt innovation und der vorteil
von dem was wir hier machen ist dass wir
diese ganze problematik von einer
realistischen warte aus ansprechen und
die ganzen komponenten versuchen in
einklang zu bringen wir werden gespannt
sein was daraus wird klaus schwab
herzlichen dank nach davos
danke schön herr seos
und das gespräch aber aus termingründen
vor zwei stunden aufgezeichnet wir haben
jetzt viele blieb menschen gesprochen
und in der tat ist es so mittlerweile
dass wir menschen bereits jetzt drei
viertel der erde für unsere zwecke
nutzen beziehungsweise für unsere zwecke
missbrauchen die folge eine million tier
und pflanzenarten stehen vor dem
aussterben nicht nur heute am
internationalen tag der biologischen
vielfalt gilt ohne tier und pflanzenwelt
kein leben fabian köhler
das leben ist zurück im lotto rita forst
ein renommierter anwalt 18 jahre haben
umweltschützer und landesbehörden daran
gearbeitet rund 28 millionen euro
investiert nun sind viele tiere und
insekten zurück die hier an der elbe in
sachsen anhalt lange nicht mehr heimisch
waren der lebensraum es eben genau für
bestimmte arten und
biotope wichtig die dadurch erhalten
bleiben und die auch für die nächsten
generationen erhalten bleiben
täglich sterben 150 arten aussagen
forscher weltweit beträgt die waldfläche
nur noch 68 prozent im vergleich zum
vorindustriellen zeitalter
drei viertel der landoberfläche sind
durch menschlichen einfluss verändert
zahlreiche beeindruckende tierarten
kämpfen ums überleben wie beispielsweise
der afrikanische waldelefant innerhalb
von 31 jahren brach sein bestand um 86
prozent ein die arten krise in der wir
stecken ist eine langfristige globale
existenzielle krise der menschheit die
ist mindestens so gefährlich wie die
klimakrise wenn nicht noch gefährlicher
für uns und umso bedauerlicher und ruhig
ja für uns ist das seit dem entstehen
der artenschutzkonferenz ionen der
konvention zur biologischen vielfalt die
sich jetzt jetzt so gut wie nichts
passiert ist nahezu alle länder des
planeten haben sich vor drei jahrzehnten
mehr artenschutz auferlegt dennoch bis
zu eine million arten sind bedroht viele
innerhalb der nächsten jahrzehnte
wissenschaftler mahnen fordern eine
dringende trendumkehr wenn in afrika die
frösche aussterben dann fressen die
weniger mückenlarven mücken sind die
tiere die die meisten menschen pro jahr
um bringen sie reißen dann als tourist
mal ins schöne afrika dort holen sie
sich malaria malaria wird von mücken
übertragen was wir an einem ende der
welt tun kommt am anderen ende der welt
auf uns zurück das gilt fürs klima das
gilt für die natur gerade in städten und
in den großen metropolen wird die
zerstörung der biologischen vielfalt
kaum wahrgenommen weltweit steht der
artenschutz selten ganz oben auf der
wirtschaftlichen oder politischen agenda
die industriestaaten müssen wieder
vorreiter werden beim naturschutz das
sind sie nicht mehr sondern unsere
konsum und produktions muster führen
dazu dass weltweit arten verloren gehen
dass ökosysteme übernutzt werden in
puncto agrarpolitik zum beispiel müssen
wir viel mehr richtung nachhaltigkeit
gehen was heißt weniger richtung
tierproduktion mehr richtung pflanze zum
beispiel oder aber auch indem ich das
verhalten ist auch in konsum
entsprechend verändere wir alle haben da
ganz gute vorstellung glaube ich davon
was für die umwelt gut ist was
schlechter
es bleibt nicht mehr viel zeit etwas zu
ändern ende august ist der nächste welt
natur gipfel eine vielleicht letzte
chance die weichen zu stellen
[Musik]
es geht um tiger elefanten und eisbären
es geht aber eben ganz genau so um die
vögel bei uns in europa zum beispiel von
denen seit 1980 knapp ein fünftel
verschwunden ist es geht um einen
globalen verlust an leben der zur
größten ökologischen krise werden könnte
seit dem ende der dinosaurier niemand
kann sagen wir haben es nicht gewusst
soviel dazu in dieser sendung jetzt die
übersicht der nachrichten von heute und
die hasloh sortiert und christian da
beginnen wir in nordrhein westfalen eine
woche nach der landtagswahl haben cdu
und grüne angekündigt gemeinsame
sondierungs gespräche aufzunehmen in der
kommenden woche wollen die beiden
parteien über eine mögliche
regierungskoalition sprechen dafür
hätten sich die gremien von cdu und
grünen ausgesprochen
ministerpräsident wüst sagte dass man
nun ausloten wolle ob es eine solide
basis für koalitionsverhandlungen gebe
angesichts der andauernden russischen
angriffe hat das ukrainische parlament
das kriegsrecht verlängert um weitere 90
tage die abgeordneten stimmten außerdem
für eine verlängerung der
generalmobilmachung als erster
ausländischer staatschef seit beginn des
kriegs hielt heute der polnische
präsident bruder eine rede im parlament
in kiew dabei betonte er die polnische
ukrainische einheit und sagte zudem dass
polen alles tun werde damit die ukraine
mitglied der europäischen union wird
bundeskanzler scholz hat heute zum
auftakt seiner afrikareise den senegal
besucht das land hat aktuell den vorsitz
der afrikanischen union inne in dakar
wurde scholz von präsident saal
empfangen bei den gemeinsamen gesprächen
ging es unter anderem um die folgen des
ukraine kriegs und um die zusammenarbeit
bei der erschließung eines gasfeldes vor
der westafrikanischen küste des illegal
hofft hier auf unterstützung
deutschlands
zum abschluss seines staatsbesuchs in
südkorea hat us-präsident beiden ein
gemeinsames kommando zentrum von
südkoreanischen und us truppen besucht
von dort beobachten beide länder die
militärische entwicklung in nordkorea
einschließlich der atomaren
bedrohungslage
anschließend ist beiden nach japan
weiter gereist dort trifft er sich unter
anderem zu gesprächen mit den
regierungschefs von japan indien und
australien
dabei soll es um den wachsenden einfluss
chinas geben
in afghanistan müssen nun auch fernseh
moderatorinnen in vollverschleierung
auftreten vor der kamera dürfen die
journalistinnen jetzt nur noch ihre
augen zeigen es handelt sich dabei um
eine anweisung der regierenden
radikalislamischen taliban seit ihrer
machtübernahme im vergangenen sommer
haben die taliban die rechte von frauen
immer weiter eingeschränkt dazu gehört
das tragen einer burka in der
öffentlichkeit oder auch das verbot für
mädchen eine weiterführende schule zu
besuchen
auf und ab in der wählergunst das gehört
für parteien dazu und das ist
selbstverständlicher teil einer
funktionierenden demokratie
wirklich problematisch wird es für die
betreffende partei wenn aufs debakel am
wahltag ein weiteres debakel am wahltag
folgt und dann noch eins wenn dazu
interne streitigkeiten und ungeklärte
vorwürfe kommen wenn nicht mehr klar ist
welche richtung die partei geht und
schließlich schlagzeilen erscheinen die
fragen steht die partei vor dem aus
womit wir bei der linken wären die sich
an diesem wochenende in niedersachsen
beim landesparteitag versuchte zu
sammeln wo die nächsten wahlen auf sie
zukommen andrea bauer
es sind wohl die beharrungskräfte die in
der linken oft wirken janine wissler
angeschlagene parteichef in einer
angeschlagenen partei tritt wieder an
ich möchte einen beitrag dazu leisten
dass die linke wieder vertrauen
zurückgewinnt dass die linke wieder
erfolgreich
ich denke dass das dringend notwendig
dass eine kraft gibt für soziale
gerechtigkeit
hinter wissler selbst liegen monate des
niedergangs 4,9 prozent bei der
bundestagswahl
sexismus und vertuschungsvorwürfe
rücktritt ihrer co parteichefin bei
allen drei landtagswahlen weit unter
fünf prozent
die partei ringt um ihre existenz und um
ihre themen der vielleicht letzte
erfolgreiche linke bodo ramelow
ministerpräsident von thüringen warnt
vor dem untergang wir brauchen wieder
eine bessere performance und zwar eine
partei die als ganzes auftritt und als
ganzes auch in der gesellschaft wirken
damit wählerinnen und wähler wissen
warum sie uns wählen klare positionen an
die sich alle halten fordert ramelow an
diesem wochenende beim landesparteitag
in thüringen und wendet sich gegen die
zitat linken unter den linken die der
nato die schuld am krieg in der ukraine
geben die sehr linken unter den linken
veranstalten wie zum beweis dass es die
linke als ganzes nicht gibt zeitgleich
ein anti nato kongress mit initiatoren
die bundestagsabgeordneten dagdelen und
hunko mit dabei linken ikone oskar
lafontaine vor kurzem ausgetreten aus
der partei um sie weiter zu quälen es
ist ein gipfel der putin verstehe die
nazi sprich die partei sagt die linke
habe mit diesem kongress nichts zu tun
sahra wagenknecht lafontaines ehefrau
sieht das allerdings anders
ob die linke damit nichts zu tun hat
wenn prominente linke ein kongress
machen kann man so oder so bewerten im
lager von wagenknecht heißt es oft nur
mit ihr seinen wahlen für die linke
überhaupt noch zu gewinnen in nrw hat
wagenknecht wahlkampf gemacht geholfen
hat es nicht die vielstimmigkeit zu der
sie selbst offensiv beiträgt beklagt nun
auch sie das problem ist eben wenn die
partei insgesamt so heterogen ist dass
die leute ja gar nicht wissen
wen sie wagenknecht wählen sie xy was
wählen sie was ist das angebot was das
profil in den nächsten tagen wie janine
wissler das team vorstellen mit dem sie
sich zur wahl schlägt weitere
kandidaturen für den parteivorsitz
werden wohl in der nächsten woche
bekannt wer die linke sein will ob es
sie in zukunft überhaupt noch gibt das
entscheidet sich beim schicksals
parteitag im juni
so jetzt sport jetzt jubel und hanna der
rb leipzig hat sich erstmals in der
vereinsgeschichte den dfb-pokal
gesichert und das wurde bei der rückkehr
zu hause natürlich ausgiebig gefeiert
tausende fans bejubelten die mannschaft
auf dem rathausplatz und nicht nur dort
danach ging es nämlich weiter in einem
offenen bus quer durch die stadt zur
festwiese am stadion
und grund zum feiern auch bei manchester
city in einem herzschlagfinale hat sich
die mannschaft den titel der englischen
premier league gesichert dem
zweitplatzierten fc liverpool und seinem
trainer jürgen klopp reichte im
fernduell 1 3 zu 1 gegen wolverhampton
nicht bei manchester city das
parallelspiel gegen aston villa
ebenfalls gewannen dank drei toren in
fünf minuten drehte city das spiel und
holte sich so seinen achten meistertitel
in der formel 1 hat der niederländer max
verstappen dem großen preis von spanien
gewonnen
auf der rennstrecke in barcelona siegte
verstappen im red bull vor seinem
teamkollegen peres und mercedes-pilot
russell weltmeister verstappen
profitierte dabei vom ausfall seines
titel-rivalen le claire der
ferrari-fahrer hatte klar in führung
liegend mit motorschaden aufgeben müssen
mit seinem vierten saisonsieg hat
verstappen nun die wm führung übernommen
botschafter des friedens an einem ort
der für den krieg geschaffen wurde die
new yorker philharmoniker in der
ehemaligen heeresversuchsanstalt der
nazis in peenemünde
der weltstar anne sophie mutter in einer
halle die einst der entwicklung von
massenvernichtungswaffen diente mehr
gegensatz geht kaum daraus kann großes
entstehen bernd mosebach ist auf usedom
wo nicht nur das konzert sofort
ausverkauft war sondern auch die
generalprobe gleich mit
sechs meter hoch der blick fest gen
osten gerichtet weithin sichtbares
zeichen der freiheit am strand von
usedom ein willkommensgruß für die new
yorker philharmoniker es ist ihr erster
auftritt seit anderthalb jahren corona
zwangspause das orchester mit weltruf
unter leitung von chefdirigent japan
schweden ist zurück im konzertsaal und
in was für eine die turbinenhalle des
kraftwerks von peenemünde
heeresversuchsanstalt der wehrmacht hier
ließen die nazis ballistische raketen
entwickeln und testen hier starben
zwangsarbeiter heute ist die anlage
museum und seit 20 jahren raum für musik
und was für welche béla bartóks konzert
für orchester sein wohl bekanntestes
werk bartok war 1943 vor den nazis in
die usa geflohen
[Musik]
meine familie war sehr betroffen von
krieg und hierzu seien weckt eine menge
traurige erinnerungen aber ich bin sehr
glücklich zu sehen dass dieser ort mit
dieser erdrückenden geschichte
verwandelt wurde in einen ort wo wir
musik machen können und musik heißt
viele wunden
zweiter höhepunkt in peenemünde das
violinkonzert anne sophie gespielt von
anne sophie mutter für sie komponiert
von andré previn ihrem verstorbenen
ehemann
auch er war vor den nazis in die usa
geflohen musik ist immer wieder der
versuch
die sprache die tausende von jahren
altes zu erneuern und zu aktualisieren
sie ist aber auch immer wieder
autobiografisch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
musik verknüpft alle enden miteinander
auch wenn es fremd tönt sie werden sehen
die emotionalität der musik wird sie
erreichen
eine virtuose in die die herzen ihres
publikums erreicht hat und ein orchester
dem die rückkehr auf die bühne gelungen
ist die new yorker gastieren übrigens
noch bis dienstag auf der insel
die emotionalität ist angekommen und was
beschäftigt uns in der kommenden woche
das clever jetzt hier ist traditionell
am sonntag der heute journal ausblick
von apple
[Musik]
der bundeskanzler auf afrika-reise bis
mittwoch wird olaf scholz den senegal
südafrika und dem niger besuchen dort im
niger sind auch deutsche soldaten im
rahmen einer ausbildungsmission im
einsatz zuletzt häuften sich die
innenpolitischen spannungen in dem
westafrikanischen land
[Musik]
zehntausende gläubiger werden ab
mittwoch nach stuttgart pilgern erzielte
102 deutsche katholikentag das motto
dieses mal leben teilen ob
kirchenreformen missbrauchsskandal oder
die folgen des ukraine kriegs es gibt
viel zu diskutieren
sie werden am donnerstag mit dem
karlspreis ausgezeichnet
svetlana tief allofs kaya veronika zepp
carlo und maria kohl es nie koffer die
drei politischen aktivistinnen bekommen
den preis für ihren mutigen einsatz
gegen das autoritäre regime in belarus
am kommenden samstag blickt die fußball
welt nach paris und dort werden im
finale der champions league real madrid
und der fc liverpool aufeinander treffen
für liverpools trainer jürgen klopp wäre
es nach 2019 der zweite titel in der
königsklasse zu sehen sein wird das mega
duell live im zdf
jetzt noch der blick auf die
wetteraussichten
morgen im norden und osten noch länger
sonnig im westen und süden aufkommende
schauer und gewitter am nachmittag und
abend lokal unwetter durch heftigen
starkregen größeren hagel und schwere
sturmböen höchstwerte 20 bis 28 grad am
dienstag noch sehr wechselhaft bei 16
bis 25 grad mittwoch und donnerstag im
norden schauer sonst meist freundlich
bei 16 bis 24 grad
wir haben diesen abend im heute-journal
begonnen mit dem großen blick auf unsere
welt wie sehr alles mit allem
zusammenhängt und wie klein und
verwundbar die erde ist das wird
vielleicht erst wirklich klar mit dem
blick von ganz weit oben
der deutsche astronaut matthias maurer
hat jetzt nach seiner rückkehr erzählt
wie das war als er oft aus dem all auf
die erde blickte und die ukraine über
flog und dann sieht man nur so ein
bisschen licht dort wo die hauptstadt
ist dann denkt man oh da ist etwas
passiert wenn man genauer hinschaut
sieht man im bereich um diese hauptstadt
herum plötzlich so kleine lichtblitze
dann weiß man oder das sind die
einschläge der raketen einerseits sind
wir im welt so weit weg von den
menschlichen problemen aber andererseits
sind wir dann doch wie das so nah dran
dass ich dieses elend diese nachher mit
eigenen augen werden mehr als 400
kilometer höhe gesehen und dann auch
natürlich auch fühlen kann
das war unsere welt an diesem sonntag ab
morgen freuen sich hier marietta slomka
und hans wolf auf sie und wir wünschen
ihnen jetzt einen angenehmen abend
[Applaus]
[Musik]